so what's your strategy to commit in
brother canada so my strategy to win big
brother canada is not to come in too
aggressive because i might be
intimidating people just the way i look
like tattoos being physically fit a
firefighter so they're probably thinking
like this guy's coming here to play
so i don't want to come in too
aggressive i want to analyze the house
know who i'm dealing with the type of
people i'm dealing with once i've kind
of figured all that out and then we
start eliminating the weak links then
that's when i'm going to turn my
throttle on and go like 100 percent calm
beast and like try and win this
cool uh what kind of personality do we
need clash of clans
i hate negative people people that are
just always toxic and negative and
complaining about everything i can't
deal with them and like i said earlier
i'm a
straight-up raw guy so i'll probably be
coming to your face and be like you
gotta cut that out it's very toxic
okay uh showmance
[Music]
indifferent is that an answer
uh you know what uh
i'll go with showmance but i don't want
to let it get into the way my game so
i have to play it smart
you